und dann haben wir das ganze auch
umgesetzt nein ich dachte ich könnte
töten einem herzen ich hab das war nun
versehen
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
x tra fries heute haben 24 weihnachten
ja meine lieben freunde und damit bildet
diese folge am 24 heute den abschluss
des projektes minecraft free zone und
ich habe in der letzten folge am 22
schon angekündigt und zwar wird bei mir
heute keinen download link in der
beschreibung stehen ich werde auch keine
große folge machen mit ganz vielen
anderen youtuber nämlich wenig die
folgen gerade aufnehme ist der
achtzehnte zwölfter und ich bin immer
noch am vorproduzieren weil wenn ihr das
video seht feiere ich wahrscheinlich
gerade weihnachten in österreich
deswegen wenn ihr den download link der
map haben möchte beziehungsweise die map
euch selber mal anschauen möchte
irgendwas hier zocken wollt dann schaut
einfach mal in die beschreibung der
anderen youtuber die heute eventuell
alle zusammen ein video hochladen oder
einzeln oder auf kommentare eingehen
oder dies machen oder die ganze welt
abfackeln aber auf jeden fall ist bei
den anderen youtuber der linken der
beschreibung für den download dieser map
und wenn ihr die zocken wollt müsse bei
den anderen youtube an vorbeischauen die
stehen ja immer in der beschreibung
verlinkt werden noch alles im projekt
mit dabei ist und sonst würde ich sagen
ist dass heute die letzte folge von
minecraft freak weiß gar nicht was ich
heute noch machen kann ich hatte mir
vorgenommen heute richtig viele fragen
noch mal zu beantworten aber fragen habe
ich einfach ein in allen folgen
irgendwie schon mal beantwortet deswegen
war ich jetzt einfach so dafür dass ich
quasi einfach so eine ganz simple folge
machte wo ich einfach jetzt eine höhle
gehe bisschen erzabbau und so weiter und
so fort
und dann einfach so ein bisschen über
dieses projekt rede wies mir gefallen
hat wie sich das ganze entwickelt hat
und ob so was eventuell nochmal kommt so
ein ganz simples let's play einfach
deswegen suche ich mir erst mal eine
höhle und wir laufen gehen horizonte
einfach mal wasser hier okay ich suche
mir jetzt eben eine höhle und wenn ich
sie dann gefunden habe
bz wer jetzt schon mal ein bisschen zu
reden ich habe richtig wenig zu essen
dabei dafür dass in höhe möchte ja jetzt
wird es einfach macht das ist auf jeden
fall noch ganz frisch ich schaue mal
einfach ich hab einfach nur noch drei
herzen
minute vergeben moment tot ich wollte
einfach so ein bisschen über micro fries
reden wie es sich entwickelt hat und ich
würde sagen ich fange einfach mal an und
zwar ganz am anfang wo ich mir gedacht
hatte kam luca maximal so einen
weihnachts projekten das wäre eventuell
ganz cool habe ich die letzten jahre ja
auch gemacht ist wie ich war nehmer
forderung jeden tag ein video
hochzuladen bis dezember habe ich nie
umsetzen können weil ich nicht so viel
zeit habe und youtube hat auch ich
hauptberuflich machen und da den ganzen
tag ein investieren kann deswegen die
ersten zehn tage habe ich meine ich
videos gemacht
ich wollte so gern ins wasser springen
da steht einfach nur einen block drauf
das traurige sache hier ist einer so
dass wasser gehüpft wie jüngst das
gemacht hat wie team das in minecraft
wahr gemacht hat flash funktioniert
sogar also hier war auf jeden fall dann
schon einer das habe ich mir erst
gedacht dass ich das jeden tag schaffen
locker ein video hochzuladen
das ganze wieder in schäbige
singleplayer let's play und so habe ich
mir gedacht allerdings war es dann halt
okay er verdient einfach im boden
allerdings war es dann halt später so
dass der sturm waffe mich nach neun oder
zehn pars oder so angeschrieben hatte
und meinte hey ein projekt da michael
fries das ganz frisch und so und da ich
auf jeden fall ab ob mitzumachen und so
warum nicht mal zusammen eine folge
aufnehmen oder so und dann habe ich mir
gedacht okay
es wäre vielleicht ganz frisch wenn ich
die map einfach online hochladen würde
und wir können alle zusammen auf einem
server zocken mit ein paar anderen
youtube eventuell auch tot sind in faro
und dann haben wir das ganze umgesetzt
ich dachte ich könnte die töten ich
laufe und ich laufe
naja jedenfalls hochgeladen und ein paar
andere youtuber eingeladen am anfang
waren es nur
ja und ich weiß nicht wie viele das noch
waren staffel ich und so weiter oder kam
halt mal mehr leute dazu letztendlich
auch noch irgendwie easy hallodri
carlotta zu meinen sie wir sind auf
toten waren auch gern mit mir zusammen
billige folgen aufnehmen und so das wird
dann ich will einfach von allen
abgeknallt wie viele wie viele mops sind
denn hier am start
es kann doch nicht sein das ist
eigentlich ein bahnhofsprojekt ganz so
viel spaghetti gegessen
ich hab so schluckauf einfach immer dann
haben wir uns auf jeden fall gedacht
okay wäre vielleicht ganz frisch wenn
wir die welt einfach mal so online
bereitstellen würden da hat jeder seine
folgen aufgenommen und das war auch
letztendlich muss ich sagen ich war am
anfang ein bisschen skeptisch weil ich
euch so gesagt hat ja das ist ein
singleplayer projekt von mir und so nur
ich allein mit euch so ganz billig und
so aber die meisten haben echt gesagt
okay es war richtig cool dass ihre
online gemacht hat weil dadurch ist die
welt quasi zu dem geworden was sie jetzt
ist und zwar megageil also ich bin zwar
gerade mitten am rumlaufen hier und kann
euch die welt jetzt nicht so gut zeigen
dass hatten in der letzten folge bin ich
ja schon ein bisschen um gelaufen aber
was mir jetzt halt auch schon wieder da
aufgefallen ist war einfach so viele
sachen geschafft also da steht ein
weihnachtsbaum dastehen geschenke über
rum da steht ein iglu jeder hat sein
häuschen alles verbunden mit wegen
werden weihnachtsmarkt ganz ganz viele
coole sachen auf jeden fall am start
dahin müssten irgendwo meine sachen
liegen oder ja da hinten liegen die ok
ich muss jetzt mal irgendwie dahin
kommen ohne dass mich die skelette da
hinten abfallende lauf einfach hinten so
ein bisschen energie stehen da hinten
direkt am rand ich musste quasi hin
ich sterbe einfach direkt wieder und ich
kann nicht mal mehr sprinten oder ich
mache eine taktik und springen über die
bühne das bringt auch nix ich musste
irgendwie loswerden dieses klette da
hinten
ich muss irgendwie nur hier an meine
sachen rankommen kommt fokussiert mich
okay die kommen jetzt beide jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt wird's spannend war
okay die haben so gewollt dann werde ich
mir jetzt ein scherzchen machen und die
richtig fertig machen jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt haben sie sich mit mir angelegt
das war eine blöde idee von denen die
teile ich nehme hier auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen was mit sorry sturm waffe
ab komme ich jetzt eben mal beim thema
zu bleiben dann haben wir halt alle
festgehalten und es hat nicht cool dass
wir das online gemacht haben wer richtig
viele coole sachen ihr seht schon hier
ich weiß genau dass ich sturm buffett
bude hier haben bei standard ein oder
andere abenteuer erlebt haben mit dies
gemacht
auch schon mal mit dabei und ich hab
echt nicht mit so vielen leuten
aufnehmen können was man halt auch echt
leid tut
ich dachte eigentlich dass ich mit jedem
mal eine folge schaffe und viele haben
mich aus dem volk eben auch mal in folge
aufnehmen und so aber das blöde ist halt
ich bin halt im urlaub vom 19
bis 30 und man muss dafür halt
vorproduzieren deswegen haben wir die
immer die videos ein bisschen zeit
versetzt und so ich hoffe auch dass
alles klappen vor produzieren aber allen
in allem wasser richtig coole idee und
wir haben richtig coole sachen auf jeden
fall hier schon zusammengebaut ich denke
das habe ich ja schon oft genug gesagt
ist es halt auch so dadurch dass sich
haben vorproduzieren bin kann ich nicht
einen downloadlink bereitstellen sowie
das die anderen heute wahrscheinlich in
ihren videos gemacht haben das habe ich
ja auch schon am anfang gesagt und zwar
dadurch dass ich die folge gerade am 19
oder am 18.12 nämlich weiß gar nicht
ganz genau weil meine oder und manchmal
um spenden und es ist auch schon - egal
jedenfalls kann ich euch keinen download
link jetzt gerade bereitstellen deswegen
acker bei den anderen usern
vorbeischauen die haben dann link in
ihrer beschreibung jetzt wird's ernst
freunde jetzt wird jetzt wird's creeper
lass dich hier alle ok erst mal schnell
die sachen hier anstatt wollen kom kom
kom kom kom überall
nee nee ihr springt bestimmt nicht meine
sachen in denen in den himmel
ich nenne ihnen diesmal nicht aber ich
muss mich auch richtig beeilen weil
meine sachen
reicht dies bauen oder so hallo hier ist
kann er nicht sein meint mein okay jetzt
wird isoliert freunde ihr hier
explodiert mir nicht hier bleibt mir
schön auf entfernungen hier geht man
schön weg ich will einfach nur eine
rüstung jetzt zurück langsam diese dinge
auch im wasser sind die schwimmen
irgendwie auf der stelle oder so ja geil
ich glaube die hälfte meiner sachen ist
jetzt irgendwie in der luft gegangen
oder weil hier die rüstung ja kommen wo
sind meine erfahrungen will meine yu na
ja meinte ich finde einfach egal ich
gehe einfach zurück apple hatten schon
genug abenteuer jetzt um beim thema zu
bleiben etwa hier ist nicht meine schuhe
ich laufe jetzt mal einfach wieder
zurück einfach noch mal kurz die stadt
ein bisschen zu zeigen und auch beim
thema bleiben zu können
ich muss wirklich sagen einige haben
gesagt hey lokal aber hey luca das ist
zwar ganz cool und so dass die welt so
online frei gegeben hat und dass jeder
da somit zocken kann von den anderen
youtube das war halt wieder angekündigt
hat ist ein singleplayer projekt von dir
und wir wollen das auch alleine bei dir
sehen und nicht dass der stürmer dabei
sondern dass auf einmal ganz viele
andere sachen gebaut wurden also das
haben natürlich auch einige geschrieben
aber ich habe immer gedacht die mehrheit
fand's cool dass die welt für andere
youtuber freigegeben wird und
dementsprechend muss ich sagen dass
eigentlich ein ganz spezifische und ich
bin auch sehr froh über diese
entscheidung dass er das so getroffen
haben weil ich meine jetzt rein
theoretisch an alle die das nicht gut
fanden das heißt auch andere youtuber
mit dabei sind
überlegt mal wenn ich das alleine gebaut
hätte hier alles wäre quasi am ende nur
der weihnachtsmarkt halb fertig mein
haus meine crew der weg ein bisschen und
ab ich hab dich doch gar nicht angeguckt
du bist ich hab das war nur ein versehen
oh mann ich habe da ganz kurz nur
einfach so man na ja sie ihr müsst euch
einfach mal vorstellen wenn ich das
ganze wirklich alleine aufgenommen hätte
hätten halt die ganzen anderen sachen
die wenn ich jetzt dahin schaue da
hinten dieses gebäude der weihnacht
formen hier vorne allgemein alles hätte
halt alles nicht da sein werden können
tun weil ich das alleine nie alles
geschafft hätte zu bauende ich nichts
gutes was ich in diesem ding hier
befindet ich glaube ihr nicht
ich habe vergessen dort fackeln
reinzustellen und jetzt ist nur ein
zombie im denken deshalb dass sie gerade
richtig viel massaker drin los naja
jedenfalls ich halt sonst ist alles
nicht bauen können dass hier hätte ich
zwar fertig gekriegt ich finde es auch
richtig cool da so ein kleines ding mit
mittig falls nicht was das wirklich
darstellen soll
finde ich aber eigentlich als fresh was
da gebaut hat die software schmelzer
zeit na ja jedenfalls ist das hier so
die welt hier ist das iglu hier ist er
wohnt ja eigentlich spitzenposten hat
einfach so eine scheiße da mein holz
leiden hier meinen meinen untergrund
habt ihr ja schon gesehen die ich über
die geschenke da das nette portal hier
der weihnachtsmarkt von gebrannten
mandeln von mir hier der schneemann von
cap und der baum von kef das heute von
sturm ii der kaninchenstall von sturm
waffe was das da hinten von gebäude ist
weiß ich nicht
hier ist eine riesige fahren hier
riesige fahren hier sind die hühnchen
jetzt so verstehen kann sich gute stimme
die männer aus wie eine ente granie ist
nicht wirklich ein karte kann gut rappen
von craft das so schön wie butter cap
kann sehr gut trainiert zerstören okay
was ist so black volvo sich auch nicht
dazu was gebaut wurde hier ist auch ein
richtig cooles gebäude
ich weiß nicht von wem das ist weil es
sieht mega cool aus kann ich hier nicht
gibt s nicht schalter oder so irgendwie
hallo 8
da richtig cool aus finde ich dass sie
text richtig cool water sind so
fernseher hier liegen so geschenke das
ist echt richtig cool darüber habe ich
mir gar nicht gedanken macht über diese
ganzen features die neutralen zu bauen
also wer hier wohnt echt respekt hier
sind richtig coole sachen am start
ich weiß gar nicht genau hier mit
kinderzimmer und allem richtig geil
das ist eine blue monkey animation sind
nie wirklich respekt an die person hier
wohnt find ich richtig geil finde ich
richtig cool das gebäude ist einfach
richtig cool guck mal hier mit seinem
mit zum wintergarten aus die person die
hier wohnen kann echt gut bauen muss ich
sagen das sieht richtig cool aus direkt
dahin geschaut und so ich weiß nicht
dass eventuell kräfte hier wohnt hat er
bisher glaube ich am meisten zeit auf
dem server investiert weil ich will mir
dabei gar nicht so sicher
hier steht auch schon dein haus noch so
einfach diese aggressive
selbsthilfegruppe für aggressive you
tube
hier geht der weg weiter dran aber das
hier ist echt muss ich sagen ist somit
das schönste gebäude was ich hier
gesehen habe
das sieht echt richtig cool aus kanada
oben steht sogar seinen baum drauf da
oben richtig geil auf diesem
wintergarten finde ich richtig cool das
gebäude
hier ist von tadeusz oder so hier ist
auch sein kleines häuschen und hier halt
überall aufs ein paar kleine sachen ich
weiß nicht wo ich glaub ich mag es auch
noch ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
meine lieben freunde
ich war als ihr hättet euch vielleicht
jetzt einen anderen abschluss für dieses
projekt erwartet ein wenig weniger
actionreich mit fragen beantworten und
so aber ich wollte euch nur quasi
eigentlich noch mal die welt zeigen und
eigentlich ein bisschen wir das projekt
reden allen der bei der höhlentour so
eine höhlentour wo wir nie irgendwie an
der hülle angekommen sind sondern
zweimal gestorben sind dadurch ein paar
sachen verloren habe das natürlich super
und ich denke das beschreibt das projekt
ich kann nicht gut bauen aber ich ganz
ganz cool mit euch halt so zu
interagieren fragen zu beantworten und
so weiter und so fort muss ich echt
sagen das projekt hat mir wirklich
richtig gut gefallen hätte ich nicht
gedacht weil ich eigentlich in letzter
zeit eher so der fan davon bin somit
bearbeiten und zu einmal das mache ich
ja hier relativ wenig allerdings kam es
trotz dessen mal richtig gut an die
bewertung waren immer bei
1999 positiv alle meinten soja minecraft
fries richtig cooles weihnachts
projektieren und so mit fragen
beantworten und weihnachtlicher musik so
richtig cool eigentlich alles verdammen
ich weiß nicht ich kann mich quasi nur
bedanken bei euch dafür dass ihr mit mir
dieses let's play durch gestanden habt
und ich habe mich wieder so ein bisschen
so gefallen gefunden einfach so wieder
folge auf 10 rabatt und labert und
labert und nicht irgendwelche projekte
wo man schneidet und alle möglich
natürlich wie kommen natürlich immer
noch weil dafür steht man kann also ein
bisschen so ein bisschen parität variete
keine ahnung aber ich würde auf jeden
fall sagen meine lieben freunde wenn
euch dieses projekt gefallen hat last
auf jeden fall eine bewertung da wenn
ihr den download link für eine map haben
wollt oder andere coole folgen sehen
wollt schaut bei festplatten bei staffel
bei hallodri sie bei allen anderen die
in dem projekt dabei sind vorbei sind
alle in der beschreibung unten verlinkt
da findet ihr dann irgendwo auch den
download link wenn ihr die map dann
selber zocken wollt und dann würde ich
sagen ich wünsche euch eine
vorweihnachtszeit ist der 24 schönen
abend mit eurer familie oder so und
heute kommt sogar jetzt noch also dieses
video kam jetzt die um 14 oder so wenn
ich das alles hier richtig vor geplant
habe nochmal im upload plan
heute abend kommt noch einen wie lok den
ich aus österreich da machen wo ich auch
noch mal so was ähnliches in richtung
weihnachten sagen wissen dass jahr
zusammenfassen und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns da wieder tschüss